[Music]
the synonyms to left us with so much
unfinished business and new stories to
be told that we can't wait to see what
is coming next in the following movie no
one even confirmed that we were ever
going to see descendants three but it
doesn't hurt to talk about all the
things that fans want to see stay tuned
until the end to know more about mal and
Harry's secret story if you love
descendants as much as we do don't
forget to subscribe and please give this
video a big thumbs up today we are going
to show you five clues in descendants -
about descendants three Houmas
unfinished business we all remember the
end of the second movie just when we
thought that everyone was going to live
happily ever after
luma surprised us by saying you didn't
think this was the end of the story did
you this is the same thing that mal said
at the end of the first descendants
movie and we all got the chance to see
the second film shortly after does that
confirm that we are soon going to see
descendants three unfortunately nothing
is guaranteed that's because this line
wasn't even in the script
so it was not even supposed to be there
no one knows if there is going to be a
third movie yet as the director Kenny
Ortega said that they are still waiting
to see how the fans will react no matter
what we know that there is still some
unfinished business with uma and we want
to see what is coming next
the actress China and McClain wants to
stay a villain so we can totally imagine
uma trying to make an unfair agreement
with mal just like her mother did in the
Little Mermaid after all she was not
interested in coming to the good side
when bin gave her the opportunity but
she can always change her mind as
Cameron boys who plays Carlos thinks
that she could come to their side and
they would all fight their parents
together no matter what we absolutely
need a third movie to see who was right
hey guys we are so excited to announce
we are producing
own original content head over to the
trendy for the best DIYs fashion tips
makeup acts and so much more we are sure
you're going to love it
and be sure to let us know what you
think in the comment section lefty here
from you see you there
Carlos and Jane it took a whole movie
for Carlos to finally ask Jane to go to
the cotillion dance with him he was so
shy that mal tried to give him a candy
that would make him tell the truth but
dude the dog ate it and started speaking
in English it was the best thing that
could happen to him at the end as man's
best friend convinced him to talk to the
girl that he loves saying that if she
doesn't love him back it means that she
is not the one and we are really happy
to see them together at the dance even
though the fairy godmother didn't even
understand that they were together no
matter what they were ready to live
happily ever after
but with these two we know that it's
going to be really interesting this is
why we want to see how they are going to
be dealing with their new relationship
in the next Descendants movie now all we
need is for Jay to find a soulmate - he
went to the cotillion dance with Loni
but they were probably just friends at
the time this is why we want to see what
will happen between these two or even if
Jay will ever find another special
someone auradon is the best place to
live a fairy tale story and we hope that
every villains kid will have the chance
to know what love is
Dizzy's opportunity as soon as we saw
dizzy lady Jermaine's granddaughter
working as a hairstylist on the Isle of
the Lost we all wondered what she was
doing there the young girl was too nice
to be a villain stuck on this island
actually she was only the victim of her
family who treated her like a servant
but we think that they were just jealous
because dizzy has everything it takes to
be a princess she wanted to go to Oregon
so badly that she gave all the
accessories that she made to Evie she
thought that if her friend wore them she
would feel like she is part of Aragon -
does he thought that she couldn't be
happier when Evie said her name on the
red carpet but something even better was
coming next she received an invitation
reading that she would have the chance
to attend our Adhan Prep Evie didn't
only ask Ben to let dizzy join them but
she also wanted to give this chance to
many other kids who lived on the Isle of
the Lost
do you know what it means we could see a
lot of new characters in descendants 3
director Kenny Ortega
even said that every once in a while he
thinks about new characters we hope that
we will also get the chance to see
characters from the animated series like
CJ hook Freddy fasoli Ren's Evan who
would you like to see in descendants
three don't be shy to answer in the
comment section below
Lonnie's new challenge as soon as we saw
the sword fight we immediately noticed
someone who stood out from the others
everyone was surprised when this person
revealed that she was actually a girl
but then when we saw it was Mulan's
daughter Lani we knew that it totally
made sense unfortunately she didn't have
the chance to join the swords and shield
team because she was a girl and it was
against the rules it didn't stop her
from saving Ben since that day jay knew
that she would have the chance to sword
fight for the school team too and if she
can't be a member of the team she is
going to be the captain Mulan was
probably proud of her daughter who
finally defeated the odds without having
to hide the fact that she was a girl
Lani was one of our favorite characters
and this is why we want to see what is
going to happen to her in descendants 3
she was even Jays date for the cotillion
dance and we are wondering if she is
ever going to be his girlfriend but it
would be even more amazing to see a
young woman who doesn't need a man we
think that all the fans would be really
happy if Lani could get a little more
attention in the movie she totally
deserves it Mao and Harry secret you
probably already know that dove Cameron
and Thomas Doherty who plays Harry hook
are dating in real life and if you don't
really care about celebrities you
absolutely notice that there is a big
chemistry on set when the two were
filming a scene together it almost
ruined the scene because these two
characters were supposed to hate each
other and their connection was too
intense this is why Dov and Thomas
decided to come up with a little story
to explain all this Mao and Harry used
to date when they were on the Isle of
the Lost
she was the baddest of the bad and he
was the baddest of the bad so they made
the perfect couple
but then she broke his heart and Harry
decided to join Emma because they both
hated now that would explain why these
two still have some feelings for each
other it would be great to hear more
about this story in descendants 3 after
all filmmakers need to explain to the
viewers why these two characters are
acting this way when they are together
let's just hope that bin won't be
jealous if you watched this video and
tell the end
forget to write team descendants in the
comments and tell us what you would like
to see in the third movie we'd love to
hear what you think and that's it four
five clues in descendants - about
descendants three for more stories like
this make sure you watch ten Disney
connections in dissonance - that will
make your jaw drop thanks for watching
[Music]